this video footage is reported to have
been taken inside a military camp in
Northern Burkina Faso
the man filming tells the captives will
kill you one after another anyone who
moves we shoot him some of the boys
appear dead others unconscious among
them is 16 year old cattle herder arama
still breathing then a soldier in
uniform drops a rock on Adam's skull the
soldiers laugh
mother saw this video shared on social
media and recognized her son I told Adam
not to wander the streets I told him to
stay close to his grandmother's house
since he was a stranger and that it was
too risky to wander around because some
people may think he was a fighter for
armed groups
we showed the footage to researchers
from Amnesty International they say the
video constitutes evidence of war crimes
committed by Burkina faso's military
those people are blinded they can they
present no danger to those men to those
soldiers or to those uh volunteers we
don't know what they are accused of they
have just been taken dropped on the
floor uh blind blindfolded and they are
throwing stones at them killing them in
a very brutal manner the military is
just abusing its power by killing people
outside the purview of international
humanitarian law
the details of the killings were
published in an investigation by the
Associated Press and the French
newspaper liberacio several French
journalists have since been thrown out
of the country the government
spokesperson denies the military are
involved in the killings he says armed
groups disguise themselves as soldiers
in order to blame the government we have
seen several types of videos that
incriminate to the soldiers of the
Burkina Faso Army along with volunteers
for the defense of the Homeland that
both a a very serious threat to the
civilian populations but also a
completely undermines the government's
narrative about
fighting against the Insurgency more
than 40 people were abducted on February
14th and have never been seen since
whilst Rights group C in this video a
brutal crime those who support burkina's
Army see Justice revenge for killings
committed by armed groups linked to
al-Qaeda in isil the video was widely
circulated among soldiers as a trophy of
War for an army that has lost control of
most of the country it now appears to be
killing children and teenagers it was
meant to protect
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera